I told you months ago and I received so
many angry emails and now we know that
it's true that Melania Trump the wife of
Donald Trump worked illegally in the
United States we now know and it's not
to Pat myself on the back the evidence
was there corporate media and they
talked about it a little bit they forgot
about it pretty quickly Trump campaign
dismissed the entire thing we now have
confirmation that Melania Trump was paid
for 10 jobs in the United States that
occurred before she was legally allowed
to work in the United States this is
from documents that have been provided
to the Associated Press
she received a green card in March of
2001 and became a citizen in 2006 she is
always maintained that she came here
legally and never violated the terms of
her immigration status however it turns
out that indeed she was working here
before she was authorized to work she
came to the u.s. from Slovenia in 1996
on a b---one b---two visitor visa and
then obtained an h-1b work visa in
October of 96 the documents showed that
prior to obtaining the work visa
she worked ten jobs I mean I I don't
know what to say I'm flabbergasted
Donald Trump the candidate who says
we're going to have borders here we're
going to build the wall we're going to
only have people who come in legally and
are here legally and are working legally
we're gonna get all the criminal illegal
aliens out lock her up right I mean
that's the whole trumpetear thing lock
her up illegal is illegal and Trump
wants to lock up the criminal illegals
Melania Trump was here she was working
and that was illegal Pat well it's funny
because Melania Trump this weekend also
announced that as first lady her top
priority would be to combat cyber
bullying an issue where her husband is
the chief right so I mean there's
there's no opposition from us on the
left about either of these issues yeah
but when your husband is the person
portraying these wrong it's really
contradictory the
line is that for Trump supporters
illegal immigrant is a racial category
it's not a legal one you're an illegal
immigrant if you look a certain way if
you come from certain countries models
from Slovenia Pat married two
billionaires there's nothing illegal
about that we're talking about a
cultural and racial designation will
have to be fair I mean you can't really
build a wall between the United States
and Slovenia it's acceptable
inconvenient although my guess is if you
went out and surveyed Trump supporters
and you said do you support building a
wall between the u.s. and Slovenia the
number of yeses would be shockingly high
and probably some Democrats too I mean I
don't want to be completely partisan
here but I'm sure there are people who
would support building that wall a wall
that is physically impossible to be
built so you know day before the
election I've been telling you about
this for months
it's it's a everything everything that
we have been suspecting about this work
situation has been proven to be true
Melania Trump one of those quote
criminal illegals that Donald Trump says
should never be allowed here in the
first place and must be deported via a
deportation force hmm always a double
standard not too far behind when it
comes to the Trump campaign huh